the latest in the murder trial of
prominent South Carolina attorney Alex
Murdock he is accused of killing his
wife and his son back in 2021. the judge
in the case ruled yesterday that
prosecutors can present evidence that he
allegedly stole money Murdoch's lawyers
say it's absurd to suggest that that is
linked to the murders Scott McFarland
has more
just hours before his wife and son were
murdered in June 2021 Alec Murdoch the
now dispared attorney and a storied
family was according to testimony
confronted about missing money
seconder the Chief Financial Officer of
Murdoch's firm testified Thursday nearly
three quarters of a million dollars were
unaccounted for and were supposed to
have been handed over to the firm after
a legal settlement I told him that I had
reason to believe that he had received
the funds himself and that I needed
proof that he had not
receive those fees themselves yes and I
needed proof that they're not yes what
did he tell you he told me again that he
assured me that the money was there
and that he could get it however the
jury hasn't heard this allegation yet
the judge has yet to rule on its
admissibility prosecutors argued an
opening statements Murdoch killed his
wife and son to divert attention from
the impending storm of financial crimes
the defense maintains Murdoch had no
reason to kill his family jurors have
seen and heard a series of other
allegations in testimony this week
including from a Murdoch family friend
who identified Alex Murdoch's voice in a
video recorded by Murdoch's son
prosecutors say it was recorded here
minutes before the murder prosecutors
also showed a social media video they
say indicates Alec Murdoch was wearing
clothes shortly before the murder
different than the freshly clean clothes
officers saw him wearing when they
arrived
this trial is expected to last several
weeks Murdoch has also accused of a
series of financial crimes but his name
is not on the witness list for the
defense Gail
so many twists and turns in this case
thank you very much Scott